aujourd'hui nous pouvons dire et mercier
à la france merci beaucoup à la france
des années que cette femme attendait ce
moment le 18 janvier 2001 il ya tout
juste vingt ans la france reconnaissait
officiellement le génocide arménien au
total plus d'1 5 million d'arméniens ont
été déportés et massacrés par les turcs
au début du 20e siècle deux soldats
accueil et langnau
il l'attrapé par le chemin de ma mère il
une âme et ray ils avaient brûlé
diab liées à l'état de manière toute nue
la communauté arménienne a tenté pendant
des années de faire reconnaître le
génocide
chaque année des commémorations avaient
lieu en france mais du côté de la classe
politique c'est le silence total
ce n'est qu'en 1980 qu'un parti prend
les devants c'est le parti communiste
lors d'une réunion à marseille qui
militent pour une reconnaissance du
massacre
plusieurs interventions embarqué cette
manifestation notamment celle de
monsieur roland barthes à riom
responsable de la commission fédérale
arménienne qui a évoqué la tragédie du
peuple arménien et demander la
reconnaissance du massacre perpétré
contre les arméniens à marseille la
communauté arménienne y est très
présente
1982 c'est toujours dans cette même
ville que gaston defferre à leur
ministre de l'intérieur reconnaît le
génocide arménien devant une foule de
1000 personnes
préciser la position du gouvernement
français et 10 jeunes ouvriront en
français
en connaissez jeu
nos relations
et délavé
reconnaissance purement symbolique car
aucune loi en france ne reconnaît
officiellement le génocide le 29 mai
c'est chose faite avec le vote d'une loi
par l'assemblée nationale ce qui veulent
adopter cet article unique lève la main
avis contraire il est adopté à quelques
pas du palais bourbon
certains arméniens sont en pleurs
d'autres laissent éclater leur joie ce
soir tenus publiquement par l'état
pensait que nous aimons que qui est
notre nation et pour nous c'est un
moment inoubliable
la loi est définitivement adoptée le 18
janvier 2001 à l'unanimité des membres
de la communauté arménienne sont
indiquées dans l'hémicycle le député
patrick devedjian d'origine arménienne
prend la parole la voix serrée des deux
grands pères de mes enfants l'un a été
déporté par les turcs pendant la
première guerre mondiale
le deuxième a été déportés par les
allemands pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
comment puis-je l'a expliqué la
différence dites le moi aujourd'hui 29
pays ont reconnu le génocide dans le
monde
parmi eux les etats-unis la russie ou
encore l'allemagne et l'argentine
[Musique]